-Our next guest is
an Emmy Award-winning writer
and actress
who you know from her work
on "Saturday Night Live,"
"A.P. Bio,"
and the film "Wine Country."
She stars in the new serie
"Girls5eva,"
with all episodes
streaming now on Peacock.
Let's take a look.
-Being a dentist
is stable and everything,
but it's no dream job.
I have a form of rosacea that'
from other people's breath
-Oh. Oh.
-Hey, didn't I hear
you got married?
-Yes. Caroline and I were
actually the first gay coupl
in the state of New York
to get...divorced.
Love doesn't always win!
Guess what!
-Please welcome back to the show
one of my favorite people in the
world, Paula Pell, everybody
-Whoo!
♪♪♪♪
-Please.
Oh, my --
-Walking carefully in my shoes
-Your beautiful shoes.
You look gorgeous.
-Thanks. They're a little high
-You know, I was saying, i
might be a little weird for yo
to be back in the building
where you worked at "SNL"
in a room without an audience.
But you and I both
wrote sketches
that felt as though they playe
in a room without an audience.
-Yes, I oftentimes
laughed very hard --
Before I left to go sleep
an hour before the read-through,
I would write something
I thought was hilarious.
And then I would go into
your producer
Mike Shoemaker's office,
and he would call me
yesterday's sweater,
'cause I smelled like
B.O. times 50,000.
And I would come in so jacked.
We didn't go do cocaine
during my era.
And I would be so jacked
and just be like,
[Laughing]
"We wrote this thing!"
And I'd be laughing so hard.
And then just smash-cut
to the table read
a couple hours later,
and I've showered,
and I've got new makeup on
and I'm just staring off, an
no one is laughing at any of it.
But I girled up
for you tonight, Seth.
-Oh, very nice.
-I girled up.
I know that, you know,
there's certain --
You dress a different way
when you go to Easter mass
than when you go fishing.
-Yeah.
-So I wanted to girl up tonigh
because I know that you like the
girls here to show their shape
[ Laughter ]
-We do.
We try not to be explicit,
in this era,
but we do like it to get out
to our guests.
-Yeah. If you have a shape
you need to show it.
-We need to see the shape.
-Yes. This is sheer, and I don't
know what I'm showing, so --
You're welcome, America.
-Congratulations on the show
This is about a girl band
from sort of the late '90s
early '00s, that reunites,
and it is allowing you
to go back to your
singing and dancing roots.
-Oh, my God. I mean,
I'm such a musical theater ner
from the time I was very young
So, just to --
There's times where I'll jus
be with my coworkers,
of these three other phenoms
And I'll just be looking at them
and be like,
this is a really huge hono
to be able to harmonize,
and harmonize with my alto lin
under your beautiful --
Because I always sing alto
So it's always funny
when I learn my part,
'cause the other parts are ver
flowery, and then they --
They're like, "Okay, and, Paula,
you're going to go --"
♪♪ And I go there
and, uh, there ♪♪
And then you just stay on
♪♪ There ♪♪
all the way
till the end of the song.
[ Laughter ]
-Were you typecast
in your early days of theater?
-Yeah.
I was always the old lady.
I was always an old --
Either a whore, as my
grandfather would call it,
or I was an usually
an old matron
that was like,
"Where are my jewels?"
-This is --
-That is -- That is --
You might think, "I don't know
Maybe she's in her 40s."
That was 14. I was 14.
[ Laughter ]
That was "Anything Goes."
-Okay.
-And I literally come through,
and I think I say
that somebody stole my jewels.
-And then what do you got there?
-And that is in college,
maybe two years later,
and that is Nurse Sandwich
from "The Elephant Man."
-Oh, wow.
-And I remember my big lin
was, "Sandwich, yes."
He would say, "Are you a nurse?"
And I went, "Sandwich, yes."
-Did you have other lines?
-It sounded like I was ordering.
Huh?
-Did you have other lines?
-I don't think I did.
[ Laughter ]
I had "other lines,"
'cause it was the '80s, but --
[ Laughter ]
-Now, do you think --
I have some other photos
from your youth.
Do you think you were someon
that, you know,
'cause a lot of times,
scouts would look for talent
for these girl bands, boy bands.
-Right.
-Do you think
if they had seen --
-I mean, I think, you know -
We all were cute
when we were young.
And, so, I think
when I look back at it,
I could have been
plucked from --
-Okay, somebody sees you
in a shopping mall.
-That's one shot.
-Yeah.
-That is when I had brown --
I had plastic braces,
which my "orthopedist" --
I had an "orthopedist" --
-Well, that explains why you got
the wrong kind of braces.
-His fingers smelled horrible.
[ Laughter ]
My orthodontist
put those braces on.
And I thought I was getting, you
know, girls would be excited -
Guys and girls would get excited
by getting those metal brace
because it was cool, in some
way. It was horrible but cool.
And I thought it was --
They never told me.
And then I got them,
and he just glued these plasti
braces on me that were clear
which immediately absorbed
the brown dye
from Coca-Cola and beef.
[ Laughter ]
And so, within about a month
I had brown blocks of plasti
on my teeth.
And that really upped my game.
-You actually just mentioned
you didn't know how sheer
your outfit was tonight.
This has been a historical
problem for you.
Yeah, this is a picture
from high school
when I was president
of a club called the Keyettes.
And everyone else in Florida and
everyone else was very skinn
and cute and beachy cute,
just cute girls in my club
and I was, like,
the solid leader of it.
And I went to the big goodby
party at the end of the year
and I wore this dress.
And if I can tell you the amount
of confidence I had that night
And, of course,
the eyes are closed
right as the picture flashes
But I have not only
my bra showing,
I have a couple buttons
unbuttoned
and my little -- my underboo
roll of flesh over that belt
And by the way,
for big ladies out there,
you'll appreciate this.
Every time you buy a dress tha
has a belt that comes with it,
the belt is like
four sizes too small.
So you buy the dress,
and you're like,
"Oh, this is cute,
and it has a belt, even."
And then you put on the belt
and it comes to here.
So, you know,
work on that, fashion.
[ Laughter ]
This is really creeping up
I'm going to show
something soon.
-We're going to let them
work on that.
And we're also going to be right
back with more from Paula Pell